bonjour à tous bienvenue au sénat pour
les traditionnelles questions
d'actualité dans un tout petit quart
d'heure maintenant place aux questions
d'actualité au gouvernement et pour
parler de toute cette actualité très
riche bien évidemment de cette semaine
est de ces jours ci au sénat jean marie
le guen bonjour bonjour c'est quand elle
était en charge des relations avec le
parlement évidemment beaucoup de travail
en ce moment parce que il ya une loi
très importante qui est en discussion au
sénat c'est la fameuse loi dite d'
emmanuel macron du ministre de
l'économie visiblement visiblement ça
tire un petit peu en longueur on a du
mal à voir le bout est ce que vous
pouvez une boule de cristal peut-être
nous dire à peu près de quand est-ce
qu'on verra le goût de cette loi abbas a
de toute façon est là dessus a été très
clair avec
mes amis sénateurs il faut absolument
que le vote ait lieu
ce 6 mai
prochain c'est ce qui a été programmé
le sénat a eu très largement le temps
plus de deux semaines jusqu'à
aujourd'hui pour examiner ce texte
alors certes il ya quinze jours d'arrêt
pour des vacances parlementaires
c'est un peu aux sénateurs de choisir
c'est le rythme s'ils veulent prendre
plus de temps la semaine prochaine ou
dans quinze jours mais je ne souhaite
pas les priver de leur temps de repos
qui est tout à fait logique mais il faut
absolument que ce soit terminé début mai
donc voilà demander un petit peu de
presser le pas quand même écouter
choisissent le passé plus de temps mais
moins de suspension de deux temps
sénatoriales où une activité plus
intense
là dessus je ne veux pas forcément me
glisser lorsqu'on prend très bien mais
il ya quelque chose qui est très
important c'est que vous fait rentrer
des amendements les uns après les autres
qu'ils n'étaient pas forcément au début
de la loi macron et donc forcément ça
allonge aussi le temps de débat je pense
que ce ses passes
j'entends cet argument mais c'est pas
ces éléments là qui allonge le débat je
pense qu'il ya eu franchement un peu de
blocages et puis bon bah il ya aussi un
rythme un règlement du temps des des
amendements au sénat qui est peut-être
un peu l'enjeu c'est d'ailleurs que
c'est là il réfléchit donc philippe
beaucoup de réformes de la part de
quelques as fait tu as fait le président
du sénat je pense est conscient du fait
qu'il faut peut-être à avoir une action
plus plus nerveuse je reste deux
secondes un petit peu pour les
téléspectateurs sur cette fameuse de
mâcon c'est la loi aussi sur le travail
du dimanche entre autres bien évidemment
il ya plein de changements mais
justement dans les amendements que vous
êtes en train d'amener les uns après les
autres c'est à dire sur l'investissement
sur des nouvelles lois en perspective
sur la croissance par exemple vous
n'avez pas l'impression que cette loi
finalement elle sert un petit peu de
voitures balais et la j'emploie un terme
peut-être que vous n'avez pas forcément
apprécié mais elle récupère un petit peu
tout sur son passage on c'est vrai que
cette loi des sujets très différent
puisqu'il s'agit de déverrouiller
j'allais dire le un accord économique et
administratif qui est assez ankylosé
donc il ya plein de petits points si je
peux me permettre de cette comparaison
avec la kinésithérapie ou avec
l'acupuncture donc il faut toucher à
plein de petits points pour essayer de
libérer le corps économiques et
administratives de ce pays donc vous
avez raison il ya pas mal de sujets qui
sont abordés très différents mais ce
n'est ça ne justifie pas j'allais dire
déjà passé 15 jours sur un texte puis à
l'avoir eu en commission spéciale
pendant quinze jours ça montre bien que
le travail a déjà été fait le travail du
dimanche sur le reste il n'y aura pas
d'avancée supplémentaires ah bah écoutez
d'abord le sénat
j'imaginais qu'il aura le dernier mot de
toute façon vous le savez très bien oui
enfin il ya aussi une commission mixte
paritaire nous verrons
voilà moi je pense que on verra bien ce
que décidera effectivement les
parlementaires en général la majorité
comme l'opposition joue son mot à dire
on est attentif vous avez peut-être
aussi compris pourquoi je vous dis cela
c'est que on a entendu martine aubry ces
derniers temps dire on ne touche pas au
travail du dimanche vous avez signé une
fameuse motion en vue du congrès du
parti socialiste et c'est pour cela
aussi que martine aubry est venue et
dans cette motion il est bien stipulé qu
on ne touchera plus au travail du
dimanche jusque là jusqu'à ce qui a été
voté en première lecture à l'assemblée
nationale vous avez cédé aussi quelque
part un petit peu en vue de ce congrès
non je ne crois pas évidemment toute la
politique le périmètre de toute l'action
gouvernementale est inclus dans ce
soutien d'un texte qui a eu le soutien
non seulement du premier ministre mais
de tous les ministres de ce gouvernement
voit l'investissement public aussi par
l'investissement la vérité est plus
grave c'est que nous venons de mettre en
place différents éléments à la fois sur
l'investissement privé sur
l'investissement public sur les
collectivités territoriales il y aura un
reprofilage en quelque sorte d'un
certain nombre de mesures d'ici quelques
jours
non pas qu'on revienne en arrière sur la
question des 11 milliards mais il ya une
façon d'être plus percutant sur la
question des investissements et sur
l'investissement privé ça a été voté au
sénat prévoyant sur intervention ce que
vous dites sur les dotations parce que
visiblement un peu beaucoup de bruit ici
au sénat comme des territoires bien
évidemment vous ne toucherait pas aux
milliards mais il peut y avoir par ci
par là quelques dérogations déjà eu des
aides passant pour les communes rurales
parce que vous savez on a touché à ce
qu'on appelle la dgf c'est à dire la
dotation de l'état aux collectivités
territoriales qui ne représentent
d'ailleurs que 25 % des ressources des
communes mais nous avons déjà créé des
politiques qui
structurent et est d'un certain nombre
de communes d'abord les communes rurales
et un fonds particulier qui a été créé
qui maintient le niveau des dotations
aux communes rurales un deuxième fonds a
été fait pour les quartiers les fameuses
villes ou communes qui ont des quartiers
en très grande difficulté une troisième
ciblage a été pour les maires bâtisseurs
donc vous voyez on dessine un paysage
elle que toi ou on incite les les
soit les territoires on est solidaire
avec les territoires en difficulté et
actif avec les territoires qu'ils se
bougent et qui veulent investir dans
l'avenir de ce pays et notamment en
matière de logement alors tous les
parlements vous êtes en charge tous les
parlements je vous parlais de
l'assemblée nationale de cette fois sur
le renseignement qui est en train d'être
examiné bientôt votée à l'assemblée
nationale est ce que vous allez
soumettre le texte au conseil
constitutionnel parce que visiblement
certains à droite et notamment françois
fillon disent que ce texte ne serait pas
constitutionnel eh bien il est dans la
liberté évidemment des parlementaires de
le déférer devant le conseil
constitutionnel vous imaginez bien que
si le gouvernement
a déposé un texte qui elle avait le
sentiment et j'allais dire au delà du
sentiment il avait vérifié que ce texte
était constitutionnelle donc c'est une
polémique qui permet à monsieur françois
fillon de prendre une posture je
constate quand même que une très large
majorité des français souhaite que dans
le respect de notre droit la lutte
contre
les différentes formes de terrorisme
et de déstabilisation de l'état soient
mises en oeuvre et de la société surtout
je regrette que pour des raisons
partisanes on voit aujourd'hui une
partie de la droite pas toute la droite
mais une partie de la droite
prendre des positions très laxiste comme
ils diraient
non non la réalité c'est qu'évidemment
nous nous prenons des positions qui sont
celles de responsabilité dans ce texte
de loi il ya deux mouvements il ya un
premier mouvement qui est un mouvement
où on rend juridiquement responsable et
contrôlables des attitudes qui ne
l'étaient pas préalablement d'un savon
de services de renseignement
premièrement c'est une avancée de la
démocratie et du droit les deuxièmes
mouvement c'est que nous renforçons les
moyens effectivement donné à ses
services de renseignements mais avec un
contrôle à trois niveaux beaucoup plus
importants contrôle interne contrôle
d'une commission de déontologie contrôle
du parlement et ça ce sont des éléments
de démocratie qui sont fondamentales
mais nous avons l'objectif de renforcer
nos services de renseignement cia si à
droite aujourd'hui on prétend ce que
j'entends un parfois je me suis
lellouche et d'autres que les services
de renseignement finalement ne sont pas
utiles à grand chose bien je crois qu'il
ya pour le moins des accords sans
vouloir être polémique sur les
responsabilités de tels propos enfin
pour renvoyer la balle c'est bien ce que
je disais mais puisque vous parliez de
laxisme je reviens sur ce qui s'est
passé il ya un épisode à l'assemblée
nationale il ya eu un vote sur un
amendement proposé par la ministre de la
garde des sceaux christiane taubira
nabot non pour restreindre les écoutes
dans les prisons christiane taubira
était mis en minorité sur cet amendement
c'est un moment n'a pas été a été rejeté
par une partie de la gauche et la droite
mans par le rapporteur le président de
la commission le responsable du groupe
et effectivement c'est comme on a fait
tout une histoire de cette affaire il
n'y a pas pu ressembler une histoire
comme non mais non on fait les histoires
sur ce qu'on veut
c'est pas des choses sérieuses parce que
le garde des sceaux c'est très bien et
elle s'est très engagé dans l'idée que
évidemment dans les prisons il fallait
aussi faire du renseignement après il ya
des questions de modalités techniques et
côte dans tous les textes de loi il
arrive que le gouvernement ne fasse pas
passer c'est quand même un comble que
aujourd'hui on s'étonne et on fasse une
affaire parce que le gouvernement
n'aurait pas été suivie par une majorité
de parlementaires
sinon est ce qu'on demande à l'assemblée
de s'aligner système mais bon ce membre
des eaux si ce n'est pas la première
fois qu'elle se retrouve en porte-à-faux
s'il n'y a pas un problème avec le jeu
mais le problème n'est pas du tout de ce
côté là le problème est de ceux qui font
une affaire de ski un dialogue entre le
ministre 15,9 avions aussi des
propositions qui étaient les siennes
remise en cause par des parlementaires
c'est tout à fait logique sur des
dispositions techniques si vous lisez ci
n'aura écouter sinon je vois pas non
seulement à quoi sert le bicamérisme
mais à quoi sert tout simplement le
débat devant l'assemblée si on si le
gouvernement fait des lois qui ne sont
plus discutés au parlement alors je vois
pas l'intérêt je reviens petit peu sur
les réformes qui ont été annoncées à
l'assemblée au sénat de la part de
claude bartolone et gérard larcher vote
obligatoire vous avez dit que vous étiez
plutôt pour moi acino actional je suis
plutôt favorable il aurait le débat
est-ce qu'il faut qu'il y ait une loi là
dessus non il faudrait si on devait
adopter une telle mesure il faudra
qu'ils aient un cadre que vous devez
évidemment écoutez j'ai dit qu'à titre
personnel j'ai 2 bras mais je suis
favorable à ce qui est un débat dans la
société non pas pour obliger les
français à voter mais pour se rendre
compte que le vote s'est pas simplement
un droit c'est aussi un devoir c'est à
dire que nous sommes dans une société me
semble-t-il moi c'était pas ma position
initialement il ya quelques années j
étais pas favorable mais j'ai évolué et
le consumérisme et je regarde la presse
de temps en temps une certaine presse
qui vient s'opposer au nom d'un une
sorte de populisme consumériste du vote
et de la politique non on est des
citoyens responsables ont les parts
donc aujourd'hui on est dans un autre
cadre démocratique
la démocratie c'est elle est aussi elle
doit forger un contrat entre le citoyen
et les institutions évidemment la
liberté totale des citoyens de voter
blanc il faut que leur vote blanc soit
reconnu et il faut aussi qu'ils puissent
facilement créer des formations
politiques mais ça apparemment quand il
ne soit ils le font jean-marie le guen
françois hollande dimanche souffler ses
bougies de trois ans presque jour pour
jour à l'elysée dans une grande émission
sur canal + qu'est ce qu'il reste à
faire pendant ces deux ans de
quinquennat est ce qu'on va changer de
braquet changer de méthode non je crois
qu'on va approfondir un certain nombre
de choses par exemple on voit bien qu'au
plan économique les clignotants sont
plutôt au vert mais les résultats
concrets ne sont pas encore
matérialisées je pense que nous allons
accélérer pour que sur le terrain de
l'emploi qui est quand même la question
essentielle sur le terrain de la
compétitivité on soit plus fort plus
dynamique le temps de la redistribution
est venu le fabricant jeu le deuxième
temps du cac et de la seule
redistribution qui compte pour moi c'est
celle de l'emploi voilà on a un niveau
d'emploi qui est inacceptable on a par
ailleurs un pouvoir d'achat je le
signale nous sommes un des rares pays
occidentaux et c'est la première fois
depuis des années et des années que nous
avons un pouvoir d'achat qui va croître
de 1 5% regarder les statistiques qui
sont donnés et arrêtons d'être dans ce
discours à vous bien sûr mais un certain
nombre de gens qui viennent
systématiquement nous parler de
problèmes de pouvoir d'achat alors que
nous sommes et d'austérité
éventuellement alors que nous sommes
dans un pays où le pouvoir d'achat crois
à mon considérer la réalité à derniers
mois évidemment vous rejoignez les bancs
des ministres y siègent au sénat le
premier ministre
manuel valls interrogé au lui aussi dans
un documentaire de canal+ décidément a
dit nicolas sarkozy qu'il était habité
par la vengeance et qu'il n'est pas il
n'aimait pas les français votre
sentiment à vous mais c'est un sentiment
que je partage avec le premier league
comme de nombreux autres voilà même si
j'aimerais faut que j'aille en séance
merci beaucoup jamais accepté notre
invitation vous allez bientôt assister
aux traditionnelles questions
d'actualité et cette semaine beaucoup de
questions sur la réforme des collèges il
y aura pas moins de trois questions sur
cette réforme qui sont posés à najat
vallaud belkacem qui est absente c'est
myriam el khomri secrétaire d'état
chargée de la politique de la ville qui
devra répondre à ces questions manuel
valls que vous avez vu sur les images
tout à l'heure lui aussi va devoir
répondre à certaines questions qui lui
sont posées notamment sur le programme
budgétaire on en a un petit peu parlé à
l'instant avec jean marie le guen est
normalement c'est trop soit marques du
groupe socialiste qui posera cette
question il y aura une question
également de vincent de l'est du groupe
union centriste qui posera une question
sur le programme de stabilité encore une
autre question sur la réforme des
collèges michel sapin lui aussi sera
interrogé on entend la cloche qui
retentit le président du sénat va
bientôt sortir du salon de départ vous
le pouvez voir sur ces images pour
gagner le plateau ici au sénat pour
présider cette séance des questions
d'actualité
et puis nous nous reviendrons un petit
peu plus tard à partir de 16h avec le
ministre de l'économie emmanuel macron
qui viendra s'expliquer un petit peu
justement sur cette loi qui est débattu
au sénat depuis maintenant près de dix
jours et qui risque de continuer encore
quelques jours visiblement ce que nous
disait jean marie le guen sait que de
toute façon il devrait être voté à
partir du 6 mai prochain quoi qu'il
arrive nous a dit le ministre en charge
des relations avec le parlement donc
nous verrons ce que nous dira emmanuel
macron lui posera également des
questions sur alcatel lucent qui était
vendue au groupe nokia vous avez
certainement entendu parler de cette
vente et puis également au tour de
renault parce qu'il ya quelques
polémiques également avec l'entreprise
française de véhicules on verra tous un
petit peu plus tard aux alentours de 16
heures dont on refait la séance dans
quelques instants la traditionnelle
question d'actualité onze questions au
programme aujourd'hui manuel valls est
présent dans l'hémicycle prémunissent
qui répondra à la deuxième question sur
le programme budgétaire et puis nous
nous reviendrons aussi dans un deuxième
temps sur un autre débat qui a lieu au
sénat sur le droit d'asile thème très
important
on va assister tout de suite aux
questions d'actualité dans quelques
secondes me dit oh n'est pas encore
totalement prêt ça ne serait tarder on
va attendre que l'air clochette annoncé
la reprise
monsieur le premier ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues l'ordre du jour appelle les
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
je vous rappelle que la séance est
retransmise en direct sur france 3 et
public sénat je rappelle aussi que ces
deux minutes trente pour chacun à
l'exception du premier ministre qui a
toujours des faveurs particulières ici
au sénat
et la parole est immédiatement un
monsieur patrick abate pour le groupe
communiste républicain citoyen vous avez
la parole mon cher collègue
seul président ce qu on est ministre on
a missionné ministre chers collègues la
question s'adresse à madame la ministre
de l'éducation nationale quarante ans
après la loi haby le collège est le
maillon faible notre système éducatif
parce qu'il aggrave les difficultés il
n'est pas ce lieu de l'égalité des
chances et d'émancipation à l'âge de la
construction individuelle de la quête
d'autonomie à ce moment charnière entre
l'école et le lycée le collège est un
lieu de sélection des chèques et de
relégation pour un trop grand nombre de
nos jeunes nous sommes comme vous
attacher au collège unique qui ne peut
pas être un collège uniforme mais à cet
endroit votre réforme pose un certain
nombre de questions le resserrement des
programmes autour du socle commun de
connaissances et la suppression de 3 à 4
heures au profit des deux pays
enseignement pratique interdisciplinaire
sont motivés par l'aspect supposé
austère de l'enseignement des
fondamentaux en opposition au caractère
supposé ludique et donc attractif des
enseignements pratiques cela est il
vraiment susceptibles de lutter contre
le décrochage scolaire le rééquilibrage
entre des enseignements fondamentaux et
les yeux pays assurera-t-il avec le même
niveau d'exigence
l'égalité entre ceux qui peuvent
bénéficier de l'entrée dans les
apprentissages de ses fondamentaux en
dehors du système scolaire et ceux qui
n'ont que l'école pour apprendre
l'organisation n'est le pays en toute
autonomie dans chaque établissement par
ailleurs ne risque-t-elle pas de mettre
en concurrence les matières tout comme
les établissements entre eux creusant de
fait les inégalités sociales et
territoriales pour ceux qui comme nous
considère avec un grand intérêt
l'apprentissage des langues vivantes et
ancien et qui regrettent qu'elle soit
des moyens de sélection l'objectif est
de les rendre accessibles à tous mais la
suppression des classes européennes et
internationales au profit de la seconde
langue en cinquième tout comme la
suppression des options latin et grec au
profit d'une sensibilisation dans les
deux pays leucate ne cache-t-elle pas en
fait un manque de moyens incompatible
avec l'objectif recherché en effet la
question des moyens ne peut être écartée
4000 équivalents temps plein pour 7100
collèges publics et privés nous paraît
insuffisant au regard des défis à
relever enfin grande absente dans cette
réforme les moyens pour la formation des
enseignants en particulier pour la
formation continue comme le montre un
récent rapport de la cour des comptes je
vous demande donc comment dans ces
conditions il sera possible d'assurer le
développement d'un collège de haut
niveau adapté à tous sur l'ensemble du
territoire et permettant de lutter
contre les inégalités et l'échec
scolaire s'agissant des conditions si la
question pour que le collège devienne le
terreau du développement des valeurs de
la république
merci pour vous répondre mon cher
collègue la parole à madame myriam el
khomri secrétaire d'état en charge de la
politique de la ville avait la parole le
ministre merci monsieur le président
mesdames les sénatrices messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur patrick
abate je tiens à excuser la ministre de
l'éducation nationale actuellement en
déplacement avec le président de la
république en suisse vous le savez le
collège aujourd'hui aggrave les
inégalités afin que tous les élèves
réussissent et apprennent mieux la
ministre de l'éducation nationale a
lancé une réforme du collège pour 2016
cette réforme consolide l'apprentissage
des fondamentaux dont le français les
mathématiques et l'histoire aucune
matière ne perde heures
parallèlement les programmes sont
entièrement revue pour qu'il soit
cohérent de la maternelle jusqu'à la
troisième il a effectivement été décidé
d'intégrer comme dans de très nombreux
pays dont les élèves réussissent mieux
des enseignements pratiques inter
disciplinaire on ouvre les perspectives
ont croisé sujet on fait travailler les
élèves en équipe dans la mesure sont les
enseignants qui connaissent les mieux
les besoins des cols des élèves la
réforme donne 20% de temps au conseil
d'administration dans chaque collège
pour qu'il puisse organiser ces
enseignements interdisciplinaire ses
marges de manoeuvre permettront aux
enseignants de répondre au mieux aux
besoins des élèves car au plus près de
ses besoins cette liberté pédagogique
donner aux enseignants et réguler les
inquiétudes sont compréhensibles mais il
ne s'agit en rien de fragiliser le cadre
national cette liberté est encadrée par
les horaires nationaux
par les programmes et par les huit
nouveaux thèmes de travail défini dans
les programmes afin de faire réussir
tous les élèves nous partageons cette
priorité que vous avez évoqué monsieur
le sénateur de mettre en place un
accompagnement personnalisé
c'est en apprentissage en petits
effectifs représenteront 3 heures en
sixième et au moins une heure en
cinquième en 4e et en 3e pour
concrétiser ces engagements les collèges
bénéficieront de nouveaux moyens
d'enseignement pour faciliter les
démarches
quatre mille temps plein accompagneront
ainsi la réforme du collège sur
l'apprentissage des langues je tiens à
vous répondre précisément non la réforme
du collège ne remet pas en cause
l'enseignement du latin non il n'y a pas
de suppression des sections
internationales
non la réforme ne pénalise pas
l'enseignement par exemple de l'allemand
dont je sais que vous êtes attachés bien
au contraire demain les 13 % d'élèves
qui pratiquent l'allemand au deuxième
langue vivante pour en compensant
commencé l'apprentissage un an plus tôt
nous allons vous le voyez en leur
permettant de mieux président me
maîtriser les savoirs fondamentaux tout
en développant les compétences du monde
actuel cette réforme permet au collège
de main de mieux faire apprendre à mieux
réussir ses airs simoneau ministre
la parole est à notre collègue françois
marque pour le groupe socialiste vous
avez la parole mon cher collègue 2
minutes 30 merci monsieur le président
ma question s'adresse au premier
ministre monsieur le premier ministre
votre gouvernement vient de faire
connaître la teneur du programme de
stabilité 2015 2018
celui ci prend appui sur un déficit
public de seulement 4% pour 2014 alors
qu'on annonçait un taux probable de 4,4
pour cent ce chiffre de 4 % est
encourageant tout le monde sait ici en
effet d'où nous venons le déficit public
était à des niveaux abyssaux en 2009 et
en 2010
et était encore et il était encore de
103 milliards d'euros en 2011 la
stratégie du gouvernement visant à la
fois au redressement de l'économie
française et à la poursuite de
l'assainissement des comptes publics
commencent à produire des résultats tant
pour les investissements et les
exportations
que pour la confiance des ménages et la
consommation
ce qui est d'ores et déjà démontré c'est
la capacité de la france à assainir ses
comptes publics par une maîtrise accrue
de ses dépenses
et sans augmentation des prélèvements
obligatoires c'est à souligner
je note d'ailleurs je note je note
d'ailleurs je note d'ailleurs sur cette
question des prélèvements
je note d'ailleurs sur cette question
des prélèvements que ceux qui à droite
réclame du gouvernement une maîtrise
fiscale accrue sont aujourd'hui les
premiers à augmenter fortement les
impôts dans les villes qui gouverne
depuis un an
j'en viens un sujet essentiel
j'en viens un sujet essentiel celui du
rythme de la réduction des déficits
structurels de la france durant les
trois années à venir le conseil de
l'union européenne a donné à la france
jusqu'au 2017 pour revenir sous 3% de
déficit public et lui recommande par
ailleurs une réduction soutenue de son
déficit structurel
faut-il suivre ce conseil jusqu'au bout
et prendre le risque de freiner la
croissance frémissante la réponse du
gouvernement à cette question et j'en
suis convaincu la bonne réponse réduire
le déficit oui mais en même temps
préserver des perspectives de croissance
d'ailleurs jugée prudente par le haut
conseil de 1% en 2015 1 5 % en 2016 et
2017 ma question est la suivante
monsieur le premier ministre pouvez vous
nous préciser quels sont les arguments
dont vous allez faire usage pour
convaincre nos partenaires européens que
dès lors qu'une trajectoire est bonne
pour la croissance et l'emploi en france
elle est aussi une bonne trajectoire
pour la croissance et l'emploi en europe
quand vous répondre la parole et à
monsieur le premier ministre manuel
valls vous avez la parole monsieur le
premier ministre et vous seuls
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
sénateur françois marc mon gouvernement
un cap et il s'y tient fermement il
fallait redresser le pays rétablir nos
comptes publics et restaurer la
compétitivité de nos entreprises et je
crois que progressivement en étant à la
fois lucide modeste bien sûr mais les
terminer nous sommes en train d'y
parvenir parce que oui il fallait
réparer vous l'avait bien dit le pays
après dix ans d'échec de la politique
économique menée par la majorité
précédent
le sénateur vous l'avez rappelé mon
gouvernement a présenté hier matin le
programme de ce type de stabilité et
christian eckert l'a fait j'imagine avec
talent hier devant votre commission des
finances ce programme dessine la
stratégie des finances publiques de la
france pour les trois prochaines années
avec des objectifs clairs que vous avez
rappelé le redressement de l'économie
française et la poursuite de
l'assainissement de nos comptes publics
oui les comptes publics étaient
dégradées nous les remettons à flot en
faisant des économies sur les dépenses
publiques comme aucun gouvernement ne
l'a fait par le passé 50 milliards sur
la période 2015 2017 depuis 2012 nous
avons fait preuve de sérieux budgétaire
le déficit public pour 2014 et de quatre
pour cent c'est mieux que prévu et dans
un contexte difficile c'est mieux que
les années précédentes et pour la
première fois depuis 2009 mais
prélèvements obligatoires se sont
stabilisés ce résultat c'est la réussite
de notre politique c'est la réussite de
cette majorité et quant à ce qui
explique qu'ils augmentent les impôts
locaux à cause de la baisse des
dotations
je leur demande d'aller voir l'exemple
de toulouse quand on va devant les
électeurs en leur disant qu'on va pas
augmenter les impôts pour obtenir leurs
suffrages et qu'on fait le contraire un
an après c'est mentir assumez vos
responsabilités dans vos communes devant
les électeurs
cette dynamique de redressement des
comptes publics va se poursuivre et elle
suivra un rythme qui ne remet pas en
cause la reprise de la croissance car
nos priorités c'est de préparer l'avenir
c'est de lutter contre les inégalités
c'est le tout faire pour la croissance
et pour et pôle emploi et c'est pour
cela que nous avons décidé de conforter
le pouvoir d'achat des ménages la baisse
de l'impôt sur le revenu que nous avons
décidé l'année dernière concernera à la
rentrée neuf millions de ménages ne
laissez pas croire un seul instant que
les impôts augmentent à cause de nous
c'est à cause aujourd'hui de
l'opposition alors que nous nous allons
les baisser au niveau national c'est
pour cela bien sûr que nous avons mise
en oeuvre des politiques de soutien aux
entreprises avec le cic eu avec le pack
de responsabilité de solidarité 40
milliards d'euros sur quatre ans nous
avons baissé le coût du travail dans un
contexte européen et international qui
s'améliore bien sûr avec la baisse du
coût du carburant et du pétrole s'ils
avaient augmenté on nous aurait demandé
de prendre un certain nombre de mesures
ils baissent c'est tant mieux pour nos
entreprises et pour les ménages avec la
baisse des taux d'intérêt et avec la
baisse de l'euro que j'avais demandé à
l'occasion de mon discours de politique
générale c'est la demande de la france
depuis trois ans et je me réjouis que
sur cette question comme sur celle des
investissements à travers le plan
juncker la parole du président de la
république était entendu par le
partenaire européen
enfin vous le savez la semaine dernière
j'ai aussi présenté des mesures fortes
pour dynamiser l'investissement privé
comme public est conscient aussi des
difficultés des collectivités
territoriales j'aurai l'occasion de
faire un certain nombre de mesures mais
en discutons actuellement avec les
associations d'élus et notamment la mfd
mesure que je pourrai présenter à la
mi-mai en tout cas le message est clair
politique de sérieux politique de
redressement mais je les ai indiqué dans
un contexte où les indicateurs vont dans
le bon sens aussi concerne la croissance
rien ne sera fait et je le dis devant
les commissaires européens rien ne sera
fait qui pourrait mettre en cause la
croissance c'est la politique de la
france est celle qui a été présentée
hier par le ministre en charge du budget
et c'est ce capcom que nous
maintiendrons merci monsieur le sénateur
merci monsieur le premier ministre la
parole est maintenant le pré collecteurs
de lait pour le groupe union des
démocrates et indépendants union
centriste avait la parole mon cher
collègue monsieur le président merci
mais monsieur le premier ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres vous
avez décidé de ne pas débattre avec la
représentation nationale des nouvelles
orientations pluriannuelles de nos
finances publiques de ce fait vous
bafouer la démocratie et droits du
parlement
faut-il rappeler au président de la
république que les parlementaires ont
eux aussi été élu pour représenter le
peuple français est que dans une
démocratie parlementaire ce sont eux qui
ont le dernier mot
vous refuser tout débat en raison et
c'est très clair pour tout le monde de
l'absence de consensus dans votre
majorité à l'assemblée et les divisions
au sein de votre parti pris en étau
entre vos orientations politiques et
l'ailé gauche du ps qui ne vous soutient
plus vous jouez leskiw le bilan
économique de la france avec ses 5,9
millions de chômeurs
mériterait pourtant un examen du pacte
de stabilité au parlement faut-il
rappeler qu'en un an le nombre de
chômeurs a augmenté de 160 mille en
france alors qu'il diminuait sur la même
période de 900 milles en zone euro
faut-il rappeler que le nombre de
défaillances d'entreprises atteint le
triste record de 62 mille cinq cent en
nous aurions aimé vous entendre confirmé
l'abandon de la promesse du président de
la république de ramener les comptes
publics à l'équilibré en 2017 nous
aurions aimé comprendre comment on peut
continuer à présenter des déficits
colossaux comme étant conjoncturelle
alors qu'ils durent depuis des années
voire des décennies
nous aurions aimé tenter une nouvelle
fois de vous convaincre que pour sortir
enfin de ses déficits que vous appelez
conjoncturel il faut aller plus loin
dans la baisse de la dépense publique en
s'appuyant sur de vraies réformes de
structure dont le pays a besoin
nous aurions aimé continuer à expliquer
à nos concitoyens que votre stratégie de
réduction du déficit se fait en réalité
sur la baisse des dotations aux
collectivités et donc sur le dos des
contribuables locaux qui vont voir leurs
impôts augmenter
nous aurions aimé que vous ayez le
courage d'affronter la représentation
nationale et surtout les divisions
internes de votre parti je déplore la
légèreté avec laquelle le président de
la république se dispense de la
représentation nationale au bénéfice de
son parti politique
nous aimerions que vous changez d'avis
il est encore temps de le faire la
démocratie en sortirait grandi en effet
dans une démocratie parlementaire des
prévisions budgétaires du gouvernement
qui n'ont pas reçu l'aval de la
représentation nationale ne peuvent
engager notre pays c'est en tout cas le
point de vue du groupe udc s le vôtre
monsieur le ministre
merci chers collègues vont vous répondre
la parole est à ce cri sur les terres du
secrétaire d'état chargé du budget il
avait la parole monsieur le ministre oui
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs des sénatrices ces
dessinateurs monsieur le sénateur vous
m'interrogez sur plusieurs sujets
notamment la question des relations si
j'ose dire du gouvernement avec le
parlement et de la transparence et de la
disponibilité dont il peut faire preuve
pour informer le parlement pour débattre
avec le parlement et je crois quand même
en la matière les exemples sont
innombrables où le débat a lieu parfois
pendant de très longues durées le jour
la nuit le samedi pourquoi pas le
dimanche et nous avons eu l'occasion
monsieur sénateurs je crois que vous
pouvez m'en donner acte sur tous les
textes budgétaires de passer des
dizaines voire des centaines d'heures
ensemble pour débattre et c'est normal
de nos questions budgétaires
je vous informe également si vous ne
saviez pas que l'ensemble des décrets je
pense au décret d'avançon été transmis à
votre assemblée votre rapporteur général
on a disposé votre commission des
finances a pu les examiner que nous
avons avec michel sapin passé hier plus
de deux heures avec les membres de votre
commission des finances et que nous
sommes à votre disposition
y compris les vacances pendant les
vacances d'ailleurs à l'assemblée
nationale la commission des finances se
réunira mercredi prochain nous y serons
l'assemblée nationale a également décidé
d'un débat de politique générale la
semaine suivante
nous y serons et nous sommes prêt
évidemment au débat au delà de ce que
vous venez de rappeler sur la forme je
dirais sur le fond vous appelez de vos
voeux plus l'économie d'abord ça a été
dit en 2014 les résultats de l'exécution
budgétaire ont montré des résultats
particulièrement positifs puisque l'état
monsieur sénateurs et vous le savez a
dépensé entre 2013 et 2014 sont des
chiffres sont pas des prévisions sont
pas des simulations 3 3 milliards de
moins d'exécutions à exécution messieurs
les sénateurs vous examinerez avec nous
la loi de règlement 3 3 milliards de
moins de dépenses de l'état les chiffres
sont têtus alors vous appelez de vos
voeux d'aller plus loin nous attendons
vos propositions
j'aurai l'occasion je crois durant cette
séance d'hier venir je suis attaché à
respecter mon temps de parole autant que
le parlement merci
la parole est maintenant aux présidents
jean bizet pour le groupe union pour un
mouvement populaire vous avez la parole
monsieur le président merci monsieur le
président sur le premier ministre
mesdames messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre des finances et des
comptes publics ou plutôt s'adresser
puisque je ne la perçois pas tué le
ministre alors même que nous débattons
du projet de loi macron que nous tentons
de redimensionner afin d'en faire un
vrai texte de croissance alors même que
la france si j'en juge par l'absence de
réformes en vue avant 2017 s'enfonce
lentement mais sûrement dans
l'immobilisme je viens me faire le
relais du profond mécontentement suscité
par votre refus d'organiser au sénat un
débat sur le programme de stabilité
avant avant l'envoi de votre projet aux
instances communautaires la commission
européenne vous invite à des efforts
budgétaires structurelles bien précis
vous en proposer d'autres la commission
européenne réclame des réformes vous
refuser le débat avec le parlement
curieuse attitude
oulis respect du processus démocratique
le disputent aux imprécisions
entretenus sur la trajectoire de vos
finances publiques imprécisions
soulevées par le haut conseil des
finances publiques qui souligne malgré
tout la prudence dans vos estimations
mais c'est bien tout en conférence des
présidents le gouvernement s'était
pourtant engagé à répondre à la demande
du sénat d'organiser ce débat un débat
que le sénat avait programmé aujourd'hui
même un débat vous en conviendrez est
essentielle au regard du semestre
européen ou à l'esprit précisément du
traité de lisbonne avant encore une fois
avant la transmission aux instances
communautaires
jeu j'avoue que je suis inquiet et
soucieux de votre attitude en la matière
donc refus de débat au sénat refus
également à l'assemblée nationale sur le
ministre permettez moi de reprendre les
propos de monsieur sapin relevé dans le
monde d'hier vous y souligner que la
transmission d'un tel document permet la
commission européenne d'exercer un droit
de regard et éventuellement un droit de
critique sur la stratégie budgétaire
monsieur le ministre vous accepter un
débat avec la commission européenne et
si j'en juge par les échos que nous
pouvons avoir de bruxelles il y aura
bien un débat sur vos orientations par
contre vous venez d'en priver la
représentation nationale alors monsieur
le ministre j'ai une question et une
seule pourquoi cette attitude pourquoi
ce silence merci
pour me répondre la parole est à
monsieur le premier ministre
monsieur bizet je vous réponds bien
volontiers christian eckert déjà répondu
et orageux croient d'autres questions
sur ce sujet important d'abord ce n'est
pas la première fois qu'il n'organise
pas un vote en propos de ce plan ça
avait été le cas
ç'avait été le cas en 2012 avec françois
fillon mais question eckert l'a dit il
ya un instant michel sapin hier à
l'assemblée nous excusons oui les
parties à washington pour une réunion du
fmi parce que c'est aussi important que
le ministre des finances soit dans ces
enceintes internationales qui se
tiennent un rythme régulier nous l'avons
répété c'est le parlement qui est
souverain le parlement qui s'ouvre un au
moment du vote de la loi de finances ou
des lois de finances comme l'a rappelé
les secrétaires d'état au budget donc il
n'y a pas besoin de créer un faux débat
ce qui me paraît essentiel en revanche
monsieur bizet c'est que nous débattions
devant les français des vrais sujets qui
les intéressent c'est à dire qu'est ce
que nous faisons les uns et les autres
qu'est ce que nous proposons pour
redresser les finances du pays nous nous
avons une stratégie nous l'avons dit
redresser les comptes dans l'état dans
lequel vous ne les avait laissés en 2012
et tout faire pour la croissance tout en
affichant ce qui paraît être importants
a rappelé tout en affichant des
priorités ses priorités c'est
l'éducation nationale c'est la sécurité
la justice et c'est l'emploi est
maintenant au delà des faux débat il
faut venir avec des contre-projets des
comptes arguments pour redresser les
finances du pays vous proposez en tout
cas l'ump de baisser les déficits de 100
à 150 milliards d'euros en tout cas
c'est ce que propose nicolas sarkozy ils
proposaient même pendant la campagne de
2012 de baisser les finances des
communes de 10 milliards d'euros et en
même temps vous nous expliquer que c'est
trop ce que nous sommes en train de
faire dans le domaine des collectivités
territoriales il faut que vous
expliquiez devant les français combien
de postes d'enseignants vous voulez
supprimer il faut que vous expliquer
devant les français combien de postes de
militaires voulaient supprimer il faut
que vous expliquer devant les français
combien de policiers et de gendarmes
vous voulez supprimer qu'il faut que
vous expliquer devant les français
combien de services publics dans les
départements ruraux vous voulez
supprimés au lieu de faire une campagne
démagogique sur ce sujet-là dit monsieur
bizet vous et vos amis enfin la vérité
sur votre programme en matière de
réduction des déficits publics quant à
la commission européenne quant à l'union
européenne
nous l'avons dit très clairement nous
avons un objectif c'est celui de la
baisse du déficit nominal nous avons une
trajectoire pour ce qui concerne le
déficit structurel mais nous avons dit
très clairement à la commission que nous
ne serions pas des préconisations qui
mettrait en cause notre stratégie en
matière de croissance la parole de la
france très forte il faut y croire c'est
vrai à la fois sur la réduction des
déficits et c'est vrai aussi en matière
d'investissement à travers les 315
milliards d'euros annoncé par le
président et juncker et c'est autour de
cela monsieur le sénateur que nous
bâtissons notre stratégie économique et
budgétaire je vous demande donc vous
d'être au clair devant les français
merci la parole
est maintenant notre collègue hervé line
malherbe les robes du rassemblement
démocratique et social européen il avait
la parole mais chers collègues merci
monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à madame ségolène neuville
secrétaire d'état chargé des personnes
handicapées de la lutte contre
l'exclusion
madame la ministre ma question sans
doute moins partisane et peut-être plus
concrète pour les populations que nous
représentons porte sur l'évolution
potentielle des politiques de handicap
au niveau départemental
trois lois cadres actuellement le champ
du handicap
la loi d'orientation du 30 juin 1975 la
loi du 10 juillet 1987 et la loi pour
l'égalité des droits et des chances des
personnes handicapées de février 2005
c'est cette dernière loi qui a permis la
création d'un lieu unique
destiné à faciliter les démarches des
personnes handicapées
la maison départementale des personnes
handicapées mdph
c'est mdph permettent dans chaque
département un accès unifié aux droits
et aux prestations prévues pour les
personnes handicapées malheureusement de
trop nombreuses charge administrative
pèse sur les personnels de ces maisons
leur volume d'activité est en hausse
depuis 2006 malgré des effectifs
constants afin d'y remédier
l'association des directeurs de maisons
départementales des personnes
handicapées a adressé le 23 mai 2014 aux
autorités publiques et aux différents
acteurs du champ du handicap
onze propositions de simplification des
démarches pour permettre aux mdph de
remplir de mieux remplir même leur
mission lors de la conférence nationale
du handicap qui s'est tenue le 11
décembre 2014 à l'elysée le président de
la république a annoncé je cite des
mesures concrètes de simplification pour
améliorer le quotidien des plus fragiles
il a également promis la
dématérialisation des échanges entre
mdps et mdph pardon et quelle allocation
familiale afin d'accélérer le traitement
des demandes d'allocation pour adultes
handicapés et de prestation
compensatrice de handicap madame la
ministre ma question est simple quel est
l'état d'avancement des travaux visant
le choc de simplification permettant de
dégager du temps humain et je répète de
dégager du temps humain
pour pardon aux mdph qui serait alors
dédiés vers davantage d'accompagnement
et vers davantage de prise en charge
adaptée et donc plus généralement
quelles sont les adaptations prévues
afin que les services low service public
local soit soutenue dans son action
quotidienne auprès des personnes
porteuses d'un handicap
je vous remercie
pour vous répondre la parole à mme
ségolène neuville secrétaire d'état
chargé des personnes handicapées
vous avez la parole de la ministre merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénatrices et sénateurs
madame la sénatrice hermeline malherbe
je veux bien sûr démarrer vos propos en
vous félicitant madame la sénatrice de
votre brillante réélection à la tête de
votre magnifique département que je
connais bien les pyrénées-orientales
je connais bien entendu votre
investissement quotidien aussi de nos
concitoyens et en particulier l'intérêt
que vous avez toujours porté à la
politique du handicap en général je ne
suis donc pas du tout étonné que vous
m'interrogez sur les maisons
départementales des personnes
handicapées et leur rôle essentiel dans
l'orientation et l'accompagnement des
personnes les mdph vous l'avez dit elles
constituent des lieux uniques
d'orientation d'accompagnement de qui
concentre les compétences pour
l'évaluation le suivi des personnes
handicapées et la création de ce guichet
unique lors de la loi de 2005 a été une
avancée malgré toutes les difficultés
qu'elles peuvent rencontrer aujourd'hui
alors vous l'avais dit il ya une très
forte montée en charge entre 2006 et
maintenant je peux quand même vous
rassurer un petit peu puisque les
demandes se stabilise désormais depuis
2012 et bien sûr les délais de réponse
sont encore trop long un peu plus de
quatre mois pour les adultes et environ
trois mois pour les enfants mais cela
progresse régulièrement alors comment
faire pour améliorer ses tâches pour
diminuer plus tôt les tâches
administratives et améliorer
l'accompagnement humain dans ces maisons
départementales du handicap et bien nous
avons pris un certain nombre de mesures
d'abord nous poursuivons le travail de
dématérialisation dont vous avez parlé
et la simplification du formulaire de
demande dans les mdph nous venons
d'étendre la durée d'attribution de ce
qu'on appelle l'âge de l'allocation
adulte handicapé de type 2 qui jusqu'à
présent était de 2 ans et qui maintenant
pour être prolongée jusqu'à cinq ans
nous venons d'allonger également la
durée de validité des certificats
médicaux qui sont adjoints aux demandes
qui durait trois mois et qui maintenant
pour en durer jusqu'à six mois et enfin
les départements peuvent désormais
mettre en place ce qu'on appelle le
tiers payant pour les aides techniques
c'est à dire ce qui permettra d'éviter
aux personnes d'avancer des sommes
importantes pour un fauteuil roulant ou
d'autres aides l'ensemble de ces mesures
évidemment permettra de renforcer le
traitement des demandes tout en
diminuant les délais de réponse et en
facilitant le travail des agents et pour
terminer je fais insisté sur un point
madame la sénatrice les départements
sont les premiers acteurs de l'action
sociale en france et vous qui êtes
présidente d'un département vous le
savez c'est vous qui avez la
connaissance des territoires c'est vous
qui avez la connaissance des habitants
c'est vous qui savez le mieux ce qui est
le plus efficace ou le moins efficace et
c'est donc ensemble que nous pouvons
continuer à améliorer ce sont les mdph
merci de cet hommage au département
madame corinne bouchoux pour le groupe
écologiste
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres chers collègues
sénatrices et sénateurs ma question
s'adresse à madame la ministre de
l'éducation nationale la réforme du
collège qui se fera pour l'essentiel par
décret en 2016 est une impérieuse
nécessité dont nous partageons tous je
pense les buts
favoriser le travail de groupe permettre
davantage d'intervention conjointe et de
pratiques interdisciplinaire des équipes
enseignantes sont des mesures
essentielles
l'augmentation des heures
d'accompagnement nous interroge dans la
mesure où ces aides ne font l'objet
d'aucune analyse des pratiques après
coup et de peu de formations permettant
de les concevoir en aval si l'on en
croit le référé sur la formation
continue des enseignants rendu par la
cour des comptes le 14 avril dernier et
l'excellent rapport sur l'aide
individuelle
se pose la question de la forme et du
fond de l'articulation de la réforme du
collège et des choix curriculaires et
interdisciplinaire du conseil supérieur
des programmes qu'en est il par ailleurs
toutes ces réformes seront vaines si
rien ne bouge en matière de non mixité
sociale de nombreux collèges où
l'homogénéité des publics scolaires
grandi en face des enseignants qui ont
bénéficié grâce à la loi de refondation
de l'école de quelques formations à la
coopération à la coproduction numérique
au travail en équipe et pour lesquels un
accompagnement des équipes associant les
acteurs éducatifs pour poursuivre
l'apprentissage du travail en commun
serait le bienvenu pour mieux apprendre
pour mieux réussir ce qui est le slogan
choisi pour cette réforme
ne faut-il pas tout d'abord et surtout
accompagné au sein même des collèges
l'évolution des pratiques pédagogiques
et avoir des collèges au public plus
mélangées cette question est dédié à
notre ancien collègue claude dilain et
aux enseignants aux familles aux
personnels et à l'équipe de direction du
collège lurçat à angers je vous remercie
pour vous répondre la parole comme
d'amis khoury et comrie secrétaire
d'état chargée de la politique de la
ville veuille parole merci monsieur le
président mesdames les sénatrices
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice corinne bouchoux en effet la
ministre de l'éducation nationale a
lancé cette grande réforme du collège en
2016 justement pour lutter contre les
inégalités pour consolider
l'apprentissage des fondamentaux tout en
permettant l'interdisciplinarité et un
meilleur apprentissage des langues
vivantes
l'accompagnement personnalisé pour tous
les élèves est un axe fort de la mise en
oeuvre de la nouvelle organisation du
collège tous les élèves bénéficieront
pendant leurs 26 heures hebdomadaires de
trois heures d'accompagnement
personnalisé en classe de 6ème et d'au
moins une heure d'accompagnement
personnalisé en classe de 5e de 4e et de
3e cet accompagnement personnalisé leur
permettra d'acquérir des méthodes de
progresser dans différentes matières et
d'approfondir leurs connaissances
mais vous avez raison pour que cette
ambition se concrétise un accompagnement
des équipes est primordial les équipes
pourront ainsi bénéficier de formations
pour les accompagner dans la mise en
oeuvre de leurs futurs projets tout au
long de l'année 2015 2016 les principaux
les inspecteurs pédagogiques seront
accompagnés dès ce printemps de sorte
que des formations puissent être
organisées sur site dans les collèges et
vous le soulignez vous le préconisez
l'articulation entre la réforme du
collège et les programmes scolaires
entre la forme et le fond est nécessaire
c'est précisément la mission qui a été
confiée au conseil supérieur des
programmes qui a publié le 13 avril
dernier les projets de contenus des
enseignements au collège dans le cadre
de cette nouvelle organisation
dans la mesure où cette réforme est
globale nous agissons aussi pour lutter
contre la ghettoïsation et favoriser la
mixité sociale sur la base des
gnostiques partager avec les
collectivités avec l'appui d'outils mis
à disposition par les acteurs et du
ministère de nouveaux secteurs de
recrutement des collèges pourront être
définis avec les conseils départementaux
volontaires pour regrouper plusieurs
établissements et favoriser ainsi mis
une meilleure mixité sociale et dans ce
cas là une procédure d'affectation
renouvelé sera mise en place c'est une
des mesures une des mesures fortes qui a
été prise lors du comité intérimaire et
à l'égalité et à la citoyenneté du 6
mars dernier
que nous avons pris sous l'égide du
premier ministre est en effet en hommage
à claude dilain c'est une mesure pour
tous les habitants des quartiers
populaires qui est extrêmement
importante et je peux vous dire qu'en
tant que secrétaire d'état à la
politique de la ville nous y travaillons
de façon extrêmement renforcée avec la
mise l'éducation merci madame la
ministre
la parole est maintenant à jacques
bernard magner pour le groupe socialiste
mais la parole mon cher collègue j'ai le
président monsieur le premier ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues ma question s'adresse à
madame la ministre de l'éducation
nationale mais j'ai bien compris que
c'est madame la ministre arrive la
politique de la ville qui répondraient
havrais la loi de refondation de l'école
qui donnait la priorité à l'école
primaire vous avez souhaité réformer le
collège qui constitue le deuxième pilier
du socle commun de connaissances de
compétences et de culture dans notre
système éducatif nous savons tous que
les évaluations nationales et
internationales montrent que le collège
actuelle aggrave la difficulté scolaire
en particulier dans les disciplines
fondamentales ainsi les études pisa
montre qu'en france entre 2002 et 2012
les collégiens ont régressé en français
en mathématiques et en histoire
géographie contrairement à ceux des
autres pays de l' ocde qui a eu en
moyenne ont progressé en france la
proportion d'élèves ne maîtrisant pas
les compétences de base en français et
de 12% au cours moyen deuxième année est
de 25% en troisième en mathématiques ses
proportions et de 9% en cours moyen 2e
année et de 13% en troisième sans mettre
en cause la compétence et l'engagement
des enseignants il faut reconnaître que
le collège et profère profondément
inégalitaire triant les élèves davantage
qu'ils ne les accompagne dans la
réussite il est peu adapté au
développement des compétences
nécessaires à la future insertion des
collégiens et on le constate
malheureusement il reste peu efficace
dans la lutte contre l'échec scolaire et
de décrochage de trop nombreux élèves on
peut donc dire que le collège actuel est
insuffisamment motivant et efficace pour
les élèves souvent anxiogène pour les
parents et parfois frustrant pour les
professeurs il fallait donc sortir de
l'impasse dans laquelle nous sommes
arrivés quarante ans après la création
du collège unique et l'ambition
républicaine dont il était porteur
aujourd'hui il est nécessaire de
prolonger la refondation globale de
l'école qui est au coeur du redressement
de notre pays voulu par le président de
la république l'enjeu de cette fondation
est contenue dans le double défi de
rétablir la performance de notre système
éducatif en assurant la réussite du plus
grand nombre et en luttant contre le
déterminisme social tout en faisant
partager les valeurs de la république
madame la ministre comment redonner de
l'efficacité éducative et réactiver la
promesse républicaine en réformant le
collège non merci pour vous répondre la
parole est à madame myriam el khomri ou
donner la parole le ministre
merci monsieur le président mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur jacques bernard
magner vous avez raison de le rappeler
aujourd'hui le collège est le maillon
faible de la scolarité des élèves
français depuis 15 ans le nombre
d'élèves en difficulté n'a cessé
d'augmenter à la fin du collège 25 % des
élèves ne maîtrise pas les compétences
de base en français et 13 % celles
nécessaires en mathématiques sans mettre
en cause les important de le préciser ni
la compétence et l'engagement des
enseignants force est aujourd'hui de
reconnaître que le collège est
inégalitaire il est monolithique dans
son approche disciplinaire il est
inadapté au développement des
compétences indispensables à la future
insertion des collégiens et peu efficace
sur l'orientation et la lutte contre le
décrochage
c'est pour cela que la ministre de
l'éducation nationale a engagé une
démarche pragmatique et globale
pragmatique parce qu'il faut partir de
ce qui marche déjà sur le terrain libéré
les capacités d'initiative des
enseignants global parce que nous devons
repenser en même temps les contenus les
pratiques d'enseignement et
l'organisation pédagogique pour répondre
aux enjeux du collège 2016 et c'est
cette ambition qui guide la refonte de
l'ensemble des programmes engagés pour
que tous les élèves acquièrent le socle
commun de connaissances de compétences
et de culture c'est cet impératif qui
doit nous conduire à améliorer la façon
de transmettre pour les professeurs et
d'apprendre pour les élèves en donnant
il est aux équipes une marge de
manoeuvre de 20% du temps d'enseignement
dans le respect bien sûr des horaires
d'ici nerfs ce temps dédié à un
apprentissage différent des savoirs
fondamentaux par le travail en petits
groupes des enseignements pratiques
interdisciplinaire où un accompagnement
dont je parlais individuelles
particulièrement renforcée est au coeur
de la nouvelle organisation du collège
l'un des problèmes du collège
aujourd'hui c'est l'ennui qui conduit
parfois les élèves au décrochage vous
l'avez souligné dans cet esprit le
développement du numérique
l'apprentissage une seconde langue
vivante dès la 5e et de la première
langue qui vend dès le cp constituent
des réponses décisives enfin le nouveau
collège deviendra un lieu
d'épanouissement et de construction de
la citoyenneté chaque établissement
devra notamment inscrit dans son projet
de vie au collège le civisme et la
célébration des symboles de la
république
chaque collège favorisera la création de
médias par les élèves pour notamment
mieux appréhender l'information et mieux
lutter contre les théories du complot et
la démocratie collégienne sera développé
c'est donc une réponse globale et
cohérente qui est aujourd'hui apportées
pour résoudre les problèmes que connaît
le collège en france aujourd'hui
merci madame la ministre
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
albéric de montgolfier pour le groupe
union pour un mouvement populaire vous
avez la parole monsieur le rapporteur
général
merci monsieur legrand du sénat monsieur
premier ministre david whissell ministre
mes chers collègues grévistes je
voudrais d'abord remercier par
anticipation par avance le ministre des
les félicitations qu'il ne manquera pas
de m'adresser pour marc élection à la
tête du conseil départemental jean merci
habillement la falaise place quand
monsieur monsieur le ministre hier lors
de votre audition par les commissions
des finances et des affaires européennes
michel sapin a indiqué que le
gouvernement ferait je le cite les 50
milliards d'euros d'économies tous les
50 milliards et rien que les 50
milliards d'euros d'économies et cette
affirmation ne serait nous surprendre
puisque en effet depuis son annonce au
début de l'année 2014 le programme de 50
milliards d'euros d'économies reste
invariable toutefois cette constance
peut surprendre alors même que le
gouvernement multiplie les annonces
nouvelle en recettes venant dépenses je
pense notamment au plan en faveur de
l'investissement qui est annoncée par le
premier ministre la semaine dernière et
qui a fait l'objet d'un amendement hier
au sénat et que comprend des mesures
dont le coût atteint 3,9 milliards
d'euros pour la période 2015 2019 à cet
égard en dépit de nos nombreuses
demandes encore hier vos indications
concernant la compensation du coût de
ces mesures demeurent particulièrement
floues comment allez vous financer ces
trois milliards 9
serait-il possible de nous apporter des
précisions à ce sujet par ailleurs la
commission européenne nous invite avec
insistance à adopter des mesures
additionnelles de consolidation des
comptes publics des mesures dont le
montant approche les 60 milliards
d'euros pour les années 2015 à 2017 il
faut d'ailleurs rappeler que la
commission identifie que la moitié des
50 milliards d'euros d'économies
annoncées par le gouvernement qui reste
fort peu documentée sauf peut être pour
les collectivités enfin le projet de
probables stabilité indique je le cite
que le gouvernement serait prêt à
prendre les mesures complémentaires pour
assurer le respect des cibles nominale
n'y at-il pas une contradiction avec
votre volonté de ne pas aller au delà
des 50 milliards d'euros d'économies
annoncées et celle de respecter votre
trajectoire de réduction des
prélèvements obligatoires pour résumé
monsieur le ministre comment allez vous
financer les mesures nouvelles les
maisons nouvelles annoncées en faveur de
l'investissement
comment ferez vous pour atteindre nos
objectifs budgétaires si la conjecture
économique s'avérait moins favorable
qu'espéré doit-on crade dans cette
hypothèse une hausse de la pression
fiscale
merci bien pour vous répondre la parole
et de monsieur christian rey kerr
secrétaire d'état chargé du budget la
parole monsieur le ministre monsieur le
président mesdames messieurs les
sénatrices et sénateurs monsieur albéric
de montgolfier monsieur rapporteur
général ou su président du conseil
départemental avec nos félicitations
ainsi qu'à toutes celles et tous ceux
ici qui je sais fait des mêmes qualités
merci de votre question sur rapporteur
général vous nous interroger sur la
façon de financer les mesures que nous
prenons je vais d'abord vous dire
comment nous ne les financerons pas
alors même que certains
ici encore présents ont eu les financer
a aidé financé par l'endettement et
c'est clairement inscrit dans les bilans
entre les années
2002 à 2012 nous ne le financerons pas
par l'endettement
deuxièmement
monsieur le rapporteur général et les
choses sont très claires de ne le
financerons pas par des hausses d'impôts
le président de la république a été très
clair le premier ministre aussi et j'ai
eu l'occasion de dire au parlement que
je m'en ferai le greffier messi tente
citera sur vous monsieur grosdidier ça
va bien se passer donc
c'est si jamais je manqué à mes devoirs
de greffiers monsieur de montgolfier je
vous invite à me les rappeler alors ni
par l'endettement ni par des hausses
d'impôts ces mesures seront financées
par des économies sur rapporteur général
et je vais vous donner quelques exemples
et quelques preuves nous avons mis en
place depuis le 1er janvier de cette
année je crois que c'était une nécessité
un certain nombre de mesures pour lutter
contre le djihadisme et pour assurer la
sécurité de notre pays et je crois que
tout le monde s'est rassemblé autour de
cette idée l'ensemble de ses dépenses
plus quelques autres atteignez quasiment
un milliard d'euros 960 exactement et
comment nous avons financé vous le savez
puisque vous avez eu communication des
décrets d'avant ce qui permettait de
trouver dans d'autres ministères de
modifier les crédits pour que ceci se
fasse de façon parfaitement transparente
nous aurons 4 milliards à faire je vous
les ai décrit hier alors si jamais
suffisamment précis à votre goût mais je
vous renvoie par exemple à l'exécution
de l'année dernière nous avons pris
trois milliards 6 en cours d'année nous
avons dit que tous les financeurs y ont
ils ont été financés et notre déficit
est et au conclu en tant que prévu donc
aucune inquiétude monsieur la pâte en
général de travailler ensemble et vous
aurez toutes les assurances que vous
voulez
mia la parole et à notre collègue
georges labazée pour le groupe
socialiste avait la parole mon cher
collègue
monsieur le président mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse madame
la ministre des affaires sociales de la
santé et des droits des femmes même la
ministre la semaine européenne de la
vaccination débute lundi 20 avril
prochain et c'est l'occasion pour
l'ensemble des acteurs de santé de
mettre en place des dispositifs afin de
favoriser une meilleure compréhension
de la politique vaccinale
tendance est à tous que dans la maîtrise
de ces risques
dans le ministre tout récemment des
événements tragiques au mit une fois de
plus en cause la sécurité des vaccins il
s'agissait là des vaccins contre les
rotavirus
mais c'est en permanence que les
autorités et les professionnels de santé
doivent rassurer pourquoi une telle
méfiance
le vaccin est un médicament particulier
à plusieurs titres il est tout d'abord
un médicament préventif qui s'adresse en
conséquence avait personne 2 le plus
souvent jeunes et en bonne santé le
vaccin est ensuite un médicament
solidaire de la mesure où il entraîne
pas seulement bénéfices sur la santé au
plan individuel mais permet également de
protéger l'entourage des personnes
vaccinées
le vaccin présente enfin une dimension
politique parce que l'obligation
vaccinale est définie par la puissance
publique la décision rendue par le
conseil constitutionnel le 20 mars
dernier confirme d'ailleurs le caractère
obligatoire de la vaccination
affirmant ainsi qu'il n'est pas
contraire à la constitution de 1958 et
rappelant la compétence du parlement
pour définir une politique de
vaccination afin de protéger la santé
individuelle et collective il convient
donc aujourd'hui d'utiliser la
vaccination de manière adaptée est
acceptable ou pour la population aussi
cette semaine européenne est l'occasion
de réponse 2 aux enjeux suivants comment
faciliter l'accès au vaccin comment
clarifier le rôle des instances
participant à la prise de décisions
comment personnaliser le suivi comment
éduquer à la vaccination les amène
prochaine par le sénat de l'ovale de
santé sera pour nous l'occasion de
prolonger le débat je voudrais
aujourd'hui madame la présidente
sa voix quelle réponse le gouvernement
entend apporter à cette urgence merci
pour vos réponses la parole est à mme
ana marisol touraine milices de la santé
vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénatrices et sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur georges labazée la
semaine européenne de la vaccination
doit être pour nous comme vous le faites
l'occasion de rappeler avec force
l'importance de la vaccination
parce que la vaccination n'appartient
pas au passé elle a évidemment permis de
sauver des millions de vies d'endiguer
la propagation de maladies graves
d'éradiquer par exemple la variole et
nous avons de grandes perspectives je
pense à la dengue un espoir sérieux
existent que nous puissions disposer
d'un vaccin mais notre mobilisation
reste nécessaire parce que il y a le
risque de voir ressurgir des maladies
parce que je vous le dit monsieur le
député nous sommes prêts au monsieur le
sénateur pardon il y a les risques de
voir ressurgir des foyers de maladies un
foyer de rougeole a été découvert dans
un collège alsacien il y a quelques
jours chez des enfants qui n'avaient pas
été vaccinés et je veux donc dire ma
préoccupation parce que aujourd'hui le
taux de vaccination des personnes âgées
est insuffisant et les comportements
réfractaires s'exprime publiquement
aujourd'hui on s'aperçoit que si il y à
de la part de nos concitoyens une
progression importante de l'adhésion on
à la vaccination en quelques années
61% des français marquée une adhésion en
2010 ils sont près de 80 % aujourd'hui
il n'empêche que nous à nous constatons
que les personnes âgées et les personnes
à risque ne se vaccinent pas
suffisamment trois orientations et été
adoptée d'une part j'ai mis en place un
programme national d'amélioration de la
politique vaccinale est fait le choix de
la simplification et de la clarification
du calendrier vaccinal ensuite le projet
de loi de modernisation de notre système
de santé dont nous débattrons comporte
plusieurs mesures pour renforcer la
couverture vaccinale est notamment
l'élargissement de la possibilité de
réaliser des vaccins dans des centres de
planification les centres de santé et
les sages femmes par exemple pourront
vacciner enfin le premier ministre a
confié à madame la députée sandrine
hurel une mission pour formuler des
recommandations visant à améliorer le
taux d'adhésion de la population et des
professionnels complets à la vaccination
mercier monsieur le sénateur le
gouvernement est mobilisé merci un
ministre la parole est maintenant madame
fabienne keller pour le groupe union
pour un mouvement populaire vous avez la
parole matière collègues
monsieur le président
monsieur le premier ministre
au fond vous allez peut-être trouvé que
notre majorité sénatoriale est un peu
insistante parce que je vais à nouveau
intervenir sur le sujet du pacte de
stabilité et de l'équilibré budgétaire
monsieur le premier ministre
vous nous avez très énergiquement
indiqué que vous prépariez le pays après
dix ans d'échec
je vous laisse cette analyse n'est près
de six cent mille chômeurs en trois ans
de gouvernements de françois hollande ça
c'est un véritable échec
je vous propose donc d'intervenir sur ce
sujet après albéric de montgolfier jean
bizet et vincent delahaye
monsieur le ministre de l'économie et
des finances nous répète à l'envi que
les trajectoire de réduction du déficit
budgétaire portées par le gouvernement
correspondent à celles de bruxelles je
cite michel sapin le débat des sanctions
européennes est aujourd'hui complètement
dépassé et pourtant
la france est dans le petit groupe des
quatre pays de la zone euro dont le
solde de public le plus dégradé avec la
slovénie le portugal et l'espagne et
pourtant sur les 4 milliards d'économies
que vous avez annoncé hier une moitié
seulement est lié vraiment à un
changement structurel l'autre moitié
c'est la conjoncture la baisse du prix
du pétrole et surtout la baisse de la
charge de la dette et nous vivons là un
effet anesthésiant
de cette conjoncture favorable
ces bonnes nouvelles de court terme ne
couvre pas la période d'engagements
demandés à bruxelles et ne correspondent
pas à des orientations de structures de
fonds dont a besoin notre pays
donc monsieur le premier ministre
quelles sont les orientations
structurelles et durables qui sont les
vôtres pour faire face sur la période
2015 2017 1 à l'effet de la baisse des
investissements des collectivités qui
aura mécaniquement un effet de baisse
sur les recettes de l'état qui
aujourd'hui est pas du tout dans le
budget
deuxièmement quels sont vos orientations
pour financer l'amortissement accéléré
des investissements des entreprises on
est plutôt d'accord mais comment allez
vous le payez troisièmement comment
allez vous financer le montage prévu
pour le respect des engagements de la
loi de programmation militaire le tout
sans augmenter les impôts comme le loup
nous le promet christian eckert mais en
matière d'impôts les français ne croit
que ce qu'il voit bref pourriez vous
nous expliquer en quoi les mesures
proposées consolideront durablement la
structure du budget de la france je vous
remercie
pour vous répondre la parole est à
monsieur le premier ministre
madame
c'est un plaisir que de répondre ici aux
questions au sénat vous savez la
considération que j'ai pour votre
assemblée et puis ma foi c'est le
premier ministre merci monsieur le
président je savais pouvoir compter sur
votre soutien
madame keller nous pouvons en effet je
suis pas sûr que ce soit par ailleurs je
peux vous rejoindre sur ce point
particulièrement utile que nous
renvoyons les uns et les autres les
chiffres de l'emploi et du chômage
parce que sinon il faudrait rappeler le
million de chômeurs supplémentaires que
nous avons trouvé en 2012 les 600
milliards supplémentaires de dette pour
le pays et le niveau de déficit je dis
cela parce que pendant que vous nous
photographier
je dis cela parce que
c'est c'est un selphy moderne je dis ça
parce que un moment où les français nous
le savons doute de l'action et de la
parole publique je rappelle que
malheureusement notre pays s'est habitué
depuis des années et un niveau de
chômage de masse insupportable pour nos
compatriotes et un niveau de déficit
beaucoup trop élevé et donc la tâche la
mission de ceux qui gouvernent c'est à
la fois de réduire ses déficits c'est ça
le sérieux budgétaire et notre
trajectoire elle a été rappelée par
christian eckert c'est d'abaisser notre
cible de déficit à 3 8% pour 2015 après
avoir réalisé mieux que prévu
c'est-à-dire 4% au lieu de 4 4 en 2014
3,3 en 2016 et 2007 en 2017 c'est à dire
être sous l'objectif des 3% et nous
l'avons obtenue par un vote unanime de
la commission et du conseil il est là
notre objectif et pour ce qui concerne
le déficit structurel ça a été rappelé
c'est les 0,5 que nous ferons en 2016
avec un certain nombre de mesures oui
budgétaire nous les faisons déjà vous
2014 en intégrant bien évidemment aussi
le niveau de l'inflation qui est un des
éléments négatifs que nous devons
intégrer dans notre projection
budgétaire mais c'est ainsi que nous
agissons sans je le répète mettre en
cause la croissance qui est désormais de
retour le rythme de redressement prévu
n'est donc pas modifiée et pour y
parvenir du fait du recul très net donc
de l'inflation qui réduit les rendements
des mesures d'économies déjà adapté un
redressement complémentaire de l'ordre
de 4 milliards d'euros et de 5 milliards
d'euros en 2016 sera nécessaire ces
cibles sont exigeantes mais elles sont
réalistes nous devons réduire les
déficits 50 milliards sur trois ans en
tenant compte de l'inflation sssa
gouverner sérieusement c'est ça gérer
sérieusement nos finances locales et par
ailleurs comme pour la première fois
comme pour la première fois il y as
enfin depuis longtemps et c'est ça le
changement par rapport à ce que nous
avons connu au cours de ces dernières
années par rapport à 2008 nous sommes en
train de rentrer dans une période sans
doute encore fragile de redressement de
la croissance c'est vrai pour la zone
euro et c'est vrai pour la france il
faut comparer ce qui est comparable
notamment par rapport à ce qui se passe
dans les pays du nord ou en allemagne
j'entends souvent prendre comme exemple
l'espagne
pardonnez moi de vous rappeler qu'il
parte d'un niveau beaucoup plus bas ce
qui explique le rebond qu'aujourd'hui
ils connaissent donc c'est à la fois cet
objectif de croissance que nous devons
conforter et la gestion de nos finances
nationales parce que c'est ainsi que
nous préparons l'avenir en préservant
nos priorités je les ai rappelé
christian eckert aussi la sécurité
l'école mais aussi le soutien aux
entreprises d'où les mesures en faveur
de l'investissement privé que j'ai
annoncée d'où les mesures en faveur de
l'investissement public que j'annoncerai
à la mi mai et face à cela madame keller
nous attendons vos propositions pour
soutenir la croissance le débat a lieu
actuellement autour du texte présenté
par emmanuel macron et j'attends aussi
vos propositions précises pour réduire
les déficits parce qu'on ne peut pas
dire en même temps qu'il ne faut pas
baisser les dotations aux collectivités
territoriales on ne peut pas dire en
même temps qu'il faut augmenter le
budget de la défense on peut pas dire en
même temps qu'il faut préserver nos
engagements en matière de sécurité alors
que vous avez baissé le nombre de
policiers et de gendarmes pendant le
quinquennat de nicolas sarkozy
bref pouvait pas expliquer qu'il faut en
même temps baissé les impôts alors que
vous les avez augmenté de 30 milliards
quand vous étiez au pouvoir il faut
mettre de l'ordre madame keller dans les
idées pour être crédible au niveau des
français merci la parole est à monsieur
philippe adnot
et la parole vous chers collègues je
vous remercie monsieur le président
monsieur le premier ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'économie de l'industrie et
du numérique
ma question est doublement d'actualité
elle est d'actualité parce que comme de
nombreux collègues je viens de faire les
campagnes départemental et je n'ai pas
eu une seule réunion où je n'ai pas été
interpellé sur la problématique de la
téléphonie mobile des zones blanches des
zones grises et également des problèmes
internet j'ai même cru un instant que
finalement la totalité des zones
blanches et des zones grises de la
france étaient rassemblés dans mon
propre département le premier ministre a
dû lui aussi entendre ce ras-le-bol
puisqu'il a proposé un plan de
résorption des 170 zones blanches et des
quelques
zones grises également en matière de
téléphonie ce sujet monsieur le ministre
a été débattu avec vous dans le cadre du
volet investissement de votre projet de
loi et je pensais que tout allait
pouvoir être réglé sauf que à la lumière
des débats je reste inquiet sur la
définition de la zone blanche et je ne
vous cache pas que si demain nous
devions avoir les mêmes critères
qu'aujourd'hui l'incompréhension voire
la colère de la population serait totale
je rappelle pour tous que le critère
c'est une un coup de téléphone qui passe
devant la mairie et s'est déclaré
non zone blanche alors que nous savons
bien que beaucoup de villages sont
totalement concerné nos concitoyens
voyage il regarde d'autres pays parfois
beaucoup moins développé que le nôtre et
ils n'admettent plus cette situation je
vous pose donc la question monsieur le
ministre les mesures que vous allez
mettre en oeuvre ne concerneront tels
que les centres bourgs ou bien couvrir
ont-elles tout le territoire faudra-t-il
encore que les collectivités locales
mettent la main à la poche accentuant
ainsi encore le sentiment de nos
concitoyens d'une france à deux vitesses
par ailleurs monsieur le ministre nous
connaissons votre volonté de dynamiser
l'économie mais vous le savez cela passe
par une accélération de l'investissement
s'agissant de l'équipement haut débit
internet pourrait-on aussi accélérer la
mobilisation du fonds national pour la
société numérique et les fonds européens
qui peuvent les compléter et surtout
pouvez-vous nous assurer que nous aurons
votre soutien je conclus a eu des
évolutions positives pour que la montée
en débit puisse être puisse relever du
financement du fsn 95 % des
investissements de la montée et les
billets seront utiles pour le très haut
débit ftth pour vous répondre la parole
est aux messieurs emmanuel macron
ministres de l'économie et du numérique
avec l'industrie merci monsieur le
président mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur adnot
vous l'avez rappelé nous avons eu ce
matin un long débat qui a conduit au
vote d'un article important je crois
qu'il faisait suite aux engagements que
le premier ministre a pris en mars
dernier et un nombre d'initiatives que
les uns et les autres vous aviez pris je
crois surtout les bancs et je vous
remercie d'ailleurs toutes sensibilités
confondues de la qualité du débat qu'on
ait ce matin et vous avez raison de le
rappeler de la sensibilité je crois
qu'ils remontaient de toutes parts sur
ce besoin alors il ya finalement de deux
interrogations qui persistent la
première en effet que couvrira que
couvre at on réellement et la deuxième
celle du financement
la priorité
chiffre est connu trop souvent c'est
celle des centres bourgs vous l'avez
rappelé les engagements seront mis dans
la loi de manière fixe et pour la
première fois de manière contraignante
qui permettront de couvrir d'ici 2010 la
mi 2017 avec des objectifs fermes pour
tous les opérateurs l'ensemble des
centres bourgs non couverts ça veut dire
170 pour la 2g et environ 2600 pour la
3g ou 4g ce sera une obligation les
opérateurs qui contreviendront pourront
être sanctionnés par l'arcep ça n'était
pas le cas jusqu'à aujourd'hui mais ça
n'est pas suffisant et vous l'avez
rappelé et donc au delà des centres
bourgs les zones qui restent blanches et
qui sont imparfaitement mesurer
aujourd'hui par les indicateurs ce qui
est ce qui suscite souvent l'indignation
quand on donne les chiffres statistiques
qui consiste à dire que presque la
totalité du territoire seraient couverts
eh bien ces zones là elles pourront
faire l'objet maintenant d'une demande
devant un guichet que l'état organise de
l'ensemble des collectivités
territoriales concernées ces clichés
c'est non seulement une organisation
structurée autour de la mission très
haut débit donc des moyens humains qui
sont mis en oeuvre ce sont des moyens
financiers et ce sera la certitude de
couvrir dans la même période précisément
ces zones d'antenne complémentaire de
relais complémentaires pour qu'il n'y
ait plus du tout de zones blanches alors
ceci suppose un financement c'est la
deuxième partie de votre question le
financement c'est d'abord celui des
opérateurs
l'ensemble de l'engagement premier que
j'ai évoqué ce sont les opérateurs qui
seront contraints l'entretien ce sont
les opérateurs qui seront contraints et
qui le financeront les financements
complémentaires pour précisément ces
zones blanches or centre-bourg et bien
l'étaler cofinancera avec les
collectivités territoriales en
mobilisant 20 millions d'euros du fn
vont conclure nous oublier nous
apporteront tous ces projets au guichet
du plan juncker est en effet à celui du
fsn pour que la part de l'état et 2 et
de l'europe soit maximale dans ce cadre
là je vais maintenant merci monsieur le
premier ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres devaient suspendre la
séance sera reprise à 16h15 pour la
suite de l'examen du projet de loi
relatif à la croissance de l'activité
avec l'égalité des chances et que le
mieux la fin de 7,0 ces questions
d'actualité au gouvernement on revient
tout de suite nous quitter
bienvenue à tous sur l'antenne de public
sénat orphée